البدايه من مستجدات القتال في سوريا دار
حيث نفى الجيش الاوكراني فقدان السيطره
على المدينه
مؤكدانا القتال العنيفه مستمره قبل ذلك
اعلنت الدفاع الروسيه سيطره الكامله على
مدينه سلدار وقالت ان السيطره على المدينه
ستسمح بقطع الامدادات عن القوات
الاوكرانيه في بخموت وانها خطوه حاسمه في
العمليات الهجوميه في اوكرانيا اداره
الوقت تواصل كتائب من القوات الخاصه
الروسيه توجهها للناحيه الشماليه نحو
مدينه التي تتمركز فيها قوه اوكرانيه
واقعه بين ليست تشانس في لوجان
من اجل السيطره على المحور الشمالي باكمله
من دانياتسك في المرحله المقبله
مريم في مساء الثانيه عشر من يناير تم
تحرير مدينه سوليدار وهو امر مهم لاستمرار
العمليات الهجوميه الناجحه في اتجاه
دوناتسك ان فرض السيطره كامله على سوليدار
يجعلو من الممكن قطع طرق الامداد للقوات
الاوكرانيه في مدينه باخموت الواقعه الى
الجنوب الغربي السيطره على سوريا
على مواقع القوات الاوكرانيه في المدينه
ومنعت بذلك نقل الاحتياطات والذخيره
واجبرت العدو على الانسحاب لخطوط دفاع
اخرى العمليات الهجوميه الناجحه لقواتنا
في سوليدار خلال الايام الثلاثه الماضيه
اسفرت عن مقتل اكثر من 700 جندي اوكراني
وتدمير اكثر من 300 قطعه سلاح تابعه
للقوات الاوكرانيه
كيف مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل ومن ماسكو
مراسله العربيه كاتيا الطعمه مرحبا بكم
ابدا معك كاتيا يبدو ان اوكرانيا ما زالت
تصر على موقفها الرافض لكل الانباء التي
يعني تاتي من سوليدار خاصه في ظل
التصريحات الاخيره عن سيطره كامل روسيه
على المدينه ما الحقيقه وكيف تنظر
الى هذه التصريحات
مرحبا خالد حقيقه يعني التصريحات السيطره
على هذه المدينه همم ليست هي اليوم الاول
التي تظهر بها هذه تصريحات كنا قد شاهدنا
خلال الايام السابقه ايضا من مجموعه التي
قالت انها قامت بالسيطره على مركز المدينه
بشكل كامل ااه وكان هناك غياب واضح
لتاكيدات الدفاع التي اكدت اليوم بدورها
بشكل رسمي السيطره الكاميرا همم على مدينه
سوليدار وكما تحدثت انها قامت بتحديد 700
مقاتل اوكرانيا هناك وكان ذلك بفضل قوات
الانسان في شمال وجنوب مدينه سردار وهذا
طبعا له اهميه كبيره كما قالت الدفاع
باهميه استراتيجيه لقطع الامدادات عن
القوات الاوكرانيه الموجوده الان في مدينه
باخ موت وهو الهدف التالي الذي سيكون لي
القوات الروسيه طبعا اريد ان اؤكد كمان
ايضا على ان هناك ايضا كان تناقض بين همم
التصريحات وزاره الدفاع وقواتر التي
بدورها كانت اكدت انها هي القوات الوحيده
الموجوده في هذه المدينه اذا كما تحدثت
بشكل رسمي الدفاع بانها تمت همم او تمت
السيطره بشكل كامل على هذه المدينه من قبل
القوات الروسيه وان القوات الاوكرانيه
هربت من هذه المدينه وكان هناك نشر
الفيديوهات على وسائل الاعلام الروسيه
التي همم نشر فيها طبعا حديث للسكان همم
المحليين في هذه المدينه عن الاوضاع هناك
وعن الاعمال القتاليه هناك وعن الوضع
بالمدينه لذلك يمكن فقط
الاعتماد على التصريحات الرسميه لوزاره
الدفاع بالاضافه لما يتم نشره من قبل همم
وسائل الاعلام الروسيه عن السيطره على هذه
المدينه بالفعل خالد
حذيفه ماذا عن كيف كيف تتعامل الان مع
واقع هذه المدينه سوليدار بعد اعلان روسيا
سيطر الكامل عليه
نعم
اوكرانيا اقرت بدخول القوات الروسيه وقوات
فاجنر الى مدينه سوليدار ولكنها تنفي
السيطره الكامله للقوات الروسيه على هذه
المدينه تقول ان القتال ما زال يجري في
المدينه الجيش الاوكراني في وضع الدفاعي
في المدينه كذلك اقرب بصعوبه الاوضاع صرح
اكثر من المسؤول ااه لكن قبل ان اتحدث عن
تصريحات المسؤولين يعني اقول لك ما شاهدته
قبل عشر دقائق فقط من هذا المباشر وهو
فيديو رساله مسجله لاحد الضباط الذي اصبح
مشهورا الان من سوليدار وهو يرسل رسائل
يوميه من هذه المدينه مصوره يعني قبل 10
دقائق نشر فيديو مصور يوضح وجود القوات
الاوكرانيه داخل سوليدار وكذلك قام بتصوير
هاتفه وهناك يوجد المدينه ويوجد الزمن
ويوجد التاريخ ثم بعد ذلك مباشره وجه
الكاميرا الى كاميرا مراقبه من كاميرات
المراقبه التي يستعملها الجيش لمراقبه
القوه يعني هو قال هو كان على كاميرا
المراقبه ايضا هنالك عدد من الجنود الروس
داخل المدينه وقال نحن في سوليدار وهذه
قوه من قوات الروسيه والان سوف يتلقون
ضربه هذا كان مجمل الرساله التي وجهها
الضابط الاوكراني من داخل مدينه سولدار
اما معنى التصريحات الرسميه فان ميلر وهي
نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني اقرد بصعوبه
الوضع في سوليدار وقالت ان القوات
الاوكرانيه في وضع الدفاعي كذلك شريف تاي
وهو الناطق الرسمي باسم القوات في الشرق
قبل حوالي نصف ساعه فقط ايضا ان نشر رساله
وقال ان القوات همم روسي الاتحاديه تتعمد
نشر مثل هذه الرسائل وهي تعتبر من ادوات
الحرب ولكن القوات الاوكرانيه في مواقعها
في موقع دفاع كذلك تحدث وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني على كسر اليوم صباحا في لقاء
التلفزيوني وتحدث عن الوضع وقال ان القوات
فاجنر تريد ان ترسل رسائل لتقول ان لديها
علو كعب على الجيش الروسي نفسه انها حتى
اقوى من الجيش الروسي وان يعني رئيس شركه
يريد ان يسيطر على هذه المدينه ليحقق
مكاسب اقتصاديه طبعا تعلمون ان هذه
المدينه يوجد بها اكبر منجم للملح في
اوروبا بشكل عام ولذلك الترغب كما قال
مفاجنا في السيطره عليها ولكنه يؤكد ان
خسائر الجيش الروسي هي 10 اضعاف خسائر
الجيش الاوكراني او كما قال ان الجيش
الروسي يخسر في اليوم حوالي 600 الى 700
جندي بينما عسر هذا الرقم فقط تخسره
القوات الاخرانيه اصل هذه التطورات خاصه
في سندار كاتيا على الداخل الروسي في
موسكو يعني خاصه في ظل ما يراه بعض
المركبين بانه قد يكون يمثل اول انتصار
مهم بعد سلسل من الخسائر والهزائم التي
بني بها الجيش الروسي في ال- همم في
الفتره السابق
صحيح ما تقول خالد هذا الانتصار او التقدم
اذا اردنا ان نقول انه تقدم للقوات
الروسيه حتى لو ان هذه المدينه هي صغيره
ولكن له دلالات كبيره ان روس يتحولت ليس
فقط كخط دفاع عن الاراضي التي سيطرت عليها
وانما الان هي بدات بالهجوم من جديد
لاسيطر على اراضي جديده
لتحرير كما تقول كامل اراضي ادباس وطبعا
هذا له كان ايجابيا على الشارع الروسي بعد
سلسله من التراجع والانسحابات التي
شاهدناها في العام السابق طبعا هذا العام
الجديد ومع بدايه الخطط التي وضعها القائد
الاعلى للقوات المسلحه الروسيه همم ثلاثه
ايضا تغييرات في همم تركيبات المسؤولين
همم عن العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا منذ
ايام هي دليل على ان روسيا تريد الان همم
دوم بعد التقويم الدوم المحرز الان المحرز
في مدينه سوليدار همم للسيطره على كامل
اراضي دمباز وبالتالي السيطر على مدينه
باخمود كما قالت وفيما بعد على كراماتوست
وصله فيانس كما تقول القوات الروسيه خالد